much or former Vice President Joe Biden
the presumptive Democratic presidential
nominee got some unsolicited advice this
week when Minnesota senator Amy
Klobuchar removed herself from the veep
stakes and O'Keefe has more on the Biden
campaign's new thinking senator Amy
Klobuchar says she shared her decision
to withdraw from the consideration with
Joe Biden in a phone call Wednesday
night I think the right thing to do
right now and I told this to Vice
President Biden is to put a woman of
color on the ticket as the next vice
president of our country I think it
would be something that would help heal
the United States I think it is
something that would really take what
has been a tragedy but also a
galvanizing moment and turn it into a
moment of joy would you be more
qualified to be vice president right now
if you weren't white all I know is that
Joe Biden needs to win CBS News has
learned Biden is still considering for
his running mate Massachusetts senator
Elizabeth Warren and several women of
color lawmakers governor's big-city
mayor's and former Obama administration
officials Biden is leading President
Trump in the polls and with his numbers
slipping the president is lashing out
telling Politico that the increased
reliance on casting votes by mail is the
biggest threat to his reelection and
that if he loses legal challenges to
increase vote by mail I think it puts
the election at risk
Biden meanwhile is now on the air with a
15 million dollar ad campaign across six
swing states next week former President
Barack Obama is set to join Biden for
their first joint campaign fundraiser
for CBS this morning Saturday at
O'Keeffe what